foreign
[Music]
hi everyone welcome to Greenup session
my name is kulan davajev and I'm a
Solutions consultant here in Google
cloud and today I'm joined here on stage
by my colleague Cynthia Wu who's the
product manager for carbon footprint
Alejandro Montenegro
who's a customer engineer based out of
Denmark and lastly I guess star speaker
Michael sudakovich who is a staff
security engineer at Uber
thank you cool
thank you
so what do you learn today
um I will start the session today with
understanding green Ops later Cynthia
will cover how we can actually measure
your carbon impact and then Alejandro
will cover optimizing your workloads for
carbon efficiency
and then Mike sorry then Michael will
share with us Uber's success journey to
becoming a leader in Cloud
sustainability
we hope you find the session today
useful and you will learn today
different tools and strategies and leave
empowered to take action in your
organizations
cool so let's get started with the first
section of today's uh session which is
understanding greenups
this is a pivotal decade in the fight
against climate change there seem to be
more natural disasters happening if not
if on weekly if not on daily basis
such as wildfires and also extreme heat
for example
I'm from London and how this is
impacting our day-to-day lives last year
in July 2022 we had extreme heat I mean
for London it was very hot and it caused
a damage to one of the collocation
services that that took down a bunch of
like holes and outage that I took down
much of Business Services
and as a result there's been a research
done where we've seen where consumers
investors and also business law changing
their behavior
firstly
consumers
we've seen in the research 79 of the
polled consumers have shown interest a
very strong preference to choose brands
that are more sustainable
secondly
more and more Investments are flowing to
businesses that have an environmental
purpose
as an example of BlackRock the largest
asset manager
has put sustainability into the
portfolio construction and is exiting
essentially companies that possess High
sustainability risk
and lastly thousands of companies have
said targets and goals and have a
roadmap in place to be more sustainable
and this is what Google is doing in the
space Google has been long committed to
sustainability and we have worked really
hard to make sure that our data centers
are one of the most efficient right now
in the market
and we are the first company of our size
to have achieved carbon neutrality in
2007.
and 100 renewable energy matching since
2017 on a global and annual basis
but we are not stopping there
we set much more ambitious goal there
will be carbon free 24 7 by 2030.
at every hour and at every location
so when you use Google Cloud know that
we have worked really hard to make sure
that we minimize our impact so when you
use our products and services by default
you are on the sustainability Journey
with us
and you can do always more on top which
is later when Michael will cover
um on what Uber has done
developer why should you
carry here today right how does this
relate to you
um with data centers around consuming
around one percent of the world's
electricity
um your approach to building your
application really matters
um you can make decisions that better
for your business and for the planet and
you can also give your teams platforms
that already have sustainability built
in
the previous research that I mentioned
actually has shown that 89 of Engineers
would choose to move to a Greener
location a region if they were present
to the choice
but besides moving regions what are the
other choices that we can make today
right and let's talk about that
sustainability Journey on gcp
when we spoke to customers and you know
discovered we discovered there are two
main paths
winning of I.T and Greening by I.T
Greening of I.T means reducing the
immediate impact of your I.T operations
and lowering Associated emissions
Greening by it is using Cloud
innervation to reimagine Solutions and
business models to be more sustainable
and green Ops falls under the first
Greening of it
and that's what we'll be covering today
in the session
what is green Ops how many of you have
heard of this term before
couple of hands I see good so for those
who don't know who haven't heard of this
term before green Ops is an approach for
carbon aware engineering and operations
culture targeted at Developers
greenups consists of three main
components understand measure and
optimize in the first section we try to
explain you the principles of green
software engineering then we move on to
the measured part which explains you the
different tools and resources that
available to you today that can measure
your carbon impact and lastly optimize
the different strategies that you can
use to reduce your emissions
let's start with the first section of
green Ops which is understand
um I'm gonna cover now very high level
landscape of Journey from electricity
consumption to output and latest Cynthia
will actually share more in detail in
this section
so running any kind of workloads
um as you may guess requires electricity
right and this electricity comes from
the grid which often is which often uses
fossil fuel power plants
um and from the renewable energy
directly procured by the user
and this energy then flows through the
electric grid
and then it Powers your you know homes
offices this this conference and our
data centers which then power your
workloads
so
not every grid as I mentioned in the
early slide is equal and why do I say
that
for example if you look at this map you
see that I mean you don't see on this
map but France it relies heavily on
nuclear
then Sweden relies heavily on hydro
and that's why you see a bit of Greener
section in Sweden and then for example
Texas relies on natural gas what does
this mean
um you know
even with particular Regional grid they
choose
as what the reason why I say it's not
equal is because for example during the
day the grade may be using solar right
but in the evening it will not because
the sun isn't out
um and on top of that
oops
and on top of that Google has been
uncoaching to procure
um your renewable energy to reduce our
environmental impact about data centers
and we publish that data in the link
below so you can have a look at the link
later after the session
and the first thing you can do today
um is to look at the link and the map
and figure out where do you have your
workloads today and how could the impact
change if it was moved to a different
region
and now I'm going to pass it over to
Cynthia who's going to take you on the
Journey of measuring carbon impact
I'll take you through the tools from
Google that you can use to help you
measure and reduce your Cloud carbon
impact
so we've heard from a lot of customers
that it is really complex to estimate
carbon emissions at a granular level
especially for cloud workloads with more
and more Google Cloud customers like you
all sitting here embark on the
sustainability journey to address
climate change it has been increasingly
important to get to a granular level of
understanding of your carbon emissions
so that you can act on them
and that is why we've built the tools at
Google to help you report on
and reduce your company's carbon
footprint before I go into a live demo
of those tools let's quick uh take a
quick peek into our tools and how we
built them
first on Google Cloud carbon footprint
it is a tool you can find in the cloud
console
and we have granular level breakdown by
service project gcp region also by the
Scopes according to the greenhouse gas
protocol
you can also export it to bigquery and
integrate it with looker and sheets so
that you can do your own customized
analysis
we also have a dedicated IEM role to uh
to to give you more SEC secure access
control
and our methodology has been reviewed
according to the greenhouse gas protocol
furthermore we have started to harness
the power of AI to give you
recommendations on how to reduce your
carbon emissions you see the numbers and
our integration for now has been the
unattended project recommender through
activeassist and I will demo that very
shortly
moving on uh Google workspace has also
recently just launched its carbon
footprint I'm really excited to announce
that here and welcome you to Twilight if
you're a workspace user you can find it
in the admin console
and similar to the gcp tool it has scope
breakdowns as well as
service level breakdowns on a monthly
basis and the methodology has also been
similarly reviewed
and you might ask it's great that you'll
provide me with the tools but how did
you arrive those numbers and how can I
trust them so let me take you through
our bottom up a methodology on how to
estimate those emissions for you and
I'll start from the electricity
consumption part which is also called
scope 2 according to the greenhouse gas
protocol
so let's imagine this is a Google data
center
and your workloads run on Google Google
data center servers right and we have a
lot a lot of a lot of servers in our
data centers and we also track energy
consumption per service on the Machine
level and that is the foundation of you
know the granular details you'll see in
our reports
so all of these represent the active
compute resources and on top of that we
reserve you know additional capacities
as adult resources to help you scale up
or down easily in Google Cloud
and that's not all of everything that
consumes energy there's also you know
ancillary facilities and overhead in our
data centers for example lighting and
air conditioning and all of these
consume energy and where did the energy
come from
and as Kula mentioned it's from the
electricity grid and also the additional
renewable energy that Google procures
so with this understanding
to construct your you know your
customers scope to emissions
we take the energy the Machine level
energy consumption number
coupled with the power usage
Effectiveness number which is
essentially telling you how efficient
our data centers are and by the way
Google data centers are some of the most
efficient around the world and we
publish our Pue numbers by location by
data center every year and we welcome
you to check out that number
and we combine that with the carbon
intensity for the specific grid that
each specific data center sits on right
so you understand that as coulomb
mentioned different locations actually
you know for the same workload may
actually translate into vastly different
carbon carbon intensity and carbon
impact
and then we combine that with service
level breakdown and and then we combine
it with your customer specific billing
account level usage data and then all of
that you know goes into your report and
gives you the granular level of
understanding of the carbon emissions
and one question I get from a lot of
customers is why don't some of my carbon
report doesn't match exactly my bill it
is because you know we use the actual
usage number to factor into our into our
accounting not your bill the actual
dollar amount because you know for some
customers you might get a discount from
Google services but the carbon that's
actually put into the atmosphere that's
impacting the environment shouldn't get
a discount and that's how we're
reflecting it here
and Beyond scope two you know from
electricity which I just walked you
through there are two other Scopes that
we also share the numbers in our reports
there's scope one in scope three so
scope one in the context of Google data
center is the the emissions from using
on-site backup diesel generators
and scope 3 is a broader category
capturing from the Google data center
perspective capturing the manufacturing
and the transportation of the servers
and the racks into our data centers as
well as building our data centers
so we give we give all three scopes of
the data to you and our reports and when
you use our reports all three of these
Scopes should factor into your
organization scope 3 data
because Google is you know just one of
the suppliers of your organization
all right and
um with that I will go into a live demo
to take you through our tools
all right great
so this is the Google Cloud carbon
footprint tool you can find it in the
Google Cloud console by searching for
carbon footprint
or you can find it in the left left
navigation panel on a carbon footprint
here
when you arrive at this page you'll see
that we have published our detailed
methodology
which is here and feel free to check it
out um you know I kind of walked you
through briefly how we arrived at it but
there's so much more details to it and
if you're interested this is a fantastic
resource for you
and here at the top you see two summary
cards we have an annual carbon footprint
summary with scope one two three level
breakdown and we also have the monthly
summary card in the Middle with a trend
chart with a month month over a month
trends
and scrolling down you see we have
monthly Trend breakdown as well as
breakdown by gcp project
gcp region where the workloads are and
the gcp products let us compute engine
networking or Cloud logging
all right and if you want to get an
understanding of the data behind this
all of these charts you can set up an
export and Export this into bigquery
and I will show you the exported data so
this is the sample of the exported data
in bigquery and you'll see we have
monthly level and billing account level
data by project
by gcp service
by location
and then with all the Scopes breakdown
that you see so you can use this data to
customize your analysis and dive into a
lot of details that's not showing up in
the UI and you might be able to uncover
even more loversible to help optimize
your Cloud for sustainability
and
here on the last last but not least on
the right hand side you see the
recommendations card and this is the
integration with the machine learning
powered active assist unattended project
recommender and you see we have
identified potential projects that are
likely idle or maybe you forgot about
and we have recommended actions here
with an estimated cost and carbon
savings if you take those actions
and moving on to the Google workspace
tool so you can find this tool in the
admin console of Google workspace Under
reporting
you'll see this is a new tag here
because it's recently launched similar
to the gcp tool you have the total
carbon footprint here and monthly cost
summary in the middle here and there's
also scope breakdowns
if you're new to carbon accounting we
welcome you to check out this quick
start video to familiarize yourselves
with the carbon accounting Concepts
and there's also charts break down by
different months and you know breakdown
by Services as you can tell Drive dogs
sheets and slides are the main
contributor to the emissions of this
particular user followed by Gmail and
some other services
there's also a more granular breakdown
here
with custom date range that you can
choose from
so and can we switch back to the the
presentation so with that hopefully now
you have a good understanding of how we
estimated the the carbon emissions in
our tools and how you can use those
tools to measure your carbon impact and
I'll pass it on to Alejandro
to
walk you through more of the strategies
on optimizing for carbon
thank you Cynthia
I'm Alejandro I'm a customer engineer
based out of coping Denver
so we just saw how you can easily get an
understanding and actually measure the
carbon fitprint generated by your Google
Cloud resources
now with this understanding ideally what
you want to do is try to optimize the
cloud usage to reduce the carbon
footprint
and this is what we have been doing over
the last couple of years with several of
companies that we work with helping to
identify different optimization
strategies that then can apply and that
fits into
their reality and that kind of work loss
so let's have a look into that
wrong button
there we go
so as I mentioned before
we have identified some optimization
strategies that in general helps you
reduce your carbon footprint and in
general have to do with actually
reducing the way you use your Google
Cloud resources
which has a side benefit that it
actually also reduce your cost which is
quite nice at least for most of the
companies that we work with
say that we do have identified some
optimization strategy to do the opposite
so
increasing your cost in favor of
reducing your carbon footprint think
about you want to move a workload from
one region to a Greener region and you
do that but The Greener region is more
expensive to run that specific workload
so have that into consideration when you
look into which kind of optimization
strategies you want to use on the slide
I have listed 12 different optimization
strategy that we have found that works
well for most of the companies and at
the top you have the easiest one to
implement like cleanup archiving region
optimization and using new CPU
architecture down to the bottom where
you have the most complex one like
optimizing machine learning training and
doing distributed infrarated machine
learning today I will not be able to
look into all of those but I have picked
a few that we believe is the best one
for most of the organizations that we
work with
so in the easiest level of
implementation effort we have created
what we call the carbon sense Suite
which is a bundle of tools that helps
you to make more informed decisions
the first one is the low carbon region
signal which is basically uh within the
Google Cloud Web console when you create
a new resource we indicate to you where
is the best region to run the specific
resource in respect to carbon footprint
as you can see in the sample hand
say that we understand that not
everybody can migrate the workloads to
Finland
or Belgium especially if you are based
out of San Francisco and your custom
base is in the U.S probably won't make
too much sense have all your workloads
in Europe
so we have created a tool that we call
the regional picker the original paper
is basically a tool that based on
certain criterias will give you a list
of recommended regions that fits to your
needs
what are those criterias country where
the traffic is coming from
what are you optimizing for is it cost
latency carbon footprint and you can
give weight into all those parameters
once you do that the tool would
basically give you a list of region that
you can use that tailored for your needs
having that understanding you can apply
organization-wide policies so you can
actually limit your users or restrict
them to only use those regions that we
have identified
by that way you ensure that actually the
right regions that choose from a carbon
print point of view
and finally we have active assist as
Center management we are continuously
adding more tools within that to help
you identify those resources that are
running for our Island and that you
probably should consider removing over
the last 30 60 or 90 days
so in a medium level of effort we have
what we call scaling resources and this
is basically the idea of taking real
advantage of the real-time elasticity of
cloud
you would say well if I'm building an
application for from scratch this is a
no-brainer as I'm probably applying the
cloud native patterns but we work with
many companies that come from an on-prem
world and are moving into cloud and
normally move the workload as is
and don't really think about this idea
of elasticity when it comes to carbon
footprint so our recommendation is look
into your workloads identify those that
are running 24 7. and don't need to do
that
low hanging fruit are normally
Dev environment test environment that
could run 5x9
once you have identified those you can
create a Skilling mechanisms you
automatically turn them off and turn
them on you can use the Google Cloud
scalar that calls a function and that
function triggered the API that actually
would turn it off or turn it on
or even you could add a use a portal so
they could go in and do it manually by
themselves so whenever a user need a
service to turn it on afterwards turn it
on
what we did figure out that many times
we see companies that many users using
the same service so we recommend you
have a monitor if somebody is trying to
turn an offer service and that service
still being used you can use that
monitor to delay the shutdown and wait
for the user to be finished to that
now this is good if you want to keep the
application as is as you migrated
ideally what you want to do is try to
refactor the application
to make it more Cloud native so you can
leverage and make use of our managed
services
for example if it's a serving API you
could use cloud run or the DK autopilot
if it's a data processing job you can
use that product data flow
and then into what we call little black
belt or the most complex one has to do
with optimizing your machine learning
so you heard today and you are heard in
the news a lot around large language
models and the potential benefits that
they can have put in your organization
but that's also another discussion how
how much those and especially the
training of those actually impact the
environment
so this is also a key topic to discuss
so what we recommend is
have a look into those existing models
that are on Google cloud and see if you
can take advantage of those and
customize them for your specific need so
you don't have the need to train a model
from scratch
so over the last couple of years we have
developed techniques that allows you to
take what we today call a foundation
model and enhance that or customize that
for your specific needs
now we used to call that automl today we
have created what we call model Garden
so we are not only exposing Google
models but we're also exposing their
third-party models that you can take
advantage of
once you decide if you want to go from
building a model from scratch or adding
an Adaptive layer what you can do is
decide where you will do the training so
it's a different thing of doing the
training of the model to deploy and
serve the model so you can decide to
actually
train them all in one of our greenest
region let's say Finland and once that
has been trained actually deployed on
any other region all over the world
another consideration is as we're seeing
more and more adoption within the
organization of machine learning we are
seeing the lack of having a
single repository where everybody can go
in and discover what our teams are doing
so we highly recommend have a repository
for those malls with the metadata with
the data that have been trained with
with the version and the feature sets so
anybody within the organization can
discolor those models and make an
informed decision can I make use of an
existing model within our organization
or do I actually have to train one from
scratch
you can also or we highly recommend you
to take advantage of the accelerator
both GPU and CPU early in April we
launched the TPU version 4 which we
deployed in a huge Hub in Oklahoma and
in Oklahoma it's run on 90 carbon free
energy
and again the final final recommendation
would be take advantage of those managed
services that we're using uh offering
within Google Cloud
the the idea of you managing the
underlying infrastructure creating VM
accessing accelerator updating the drive
and so on can be a hero let Google do
that for you and we will optimize the
amount of resources assigned to your
trainer
so
the question I get most often is okay
how do we get started and the answer is
normally well it depends it depends on
your reality what are your type of
workloads what are you optimizing for
how is it impacting in your cost how is
it impacting in your actual carbon
footprint what we do recommend have a
look at those 12 optimization strategies
that we have identified look into which
one fits into what you're looking for
implemented
measure with the carbon footprint
dashboard get the feedback understand
was it valuable to do that
implementation if yes do more of that if
not don't into another optimization
strategy but again I would say how to
get started and what is the journey you
should follow is unique for each one of
the reality of your organization and for
that reason we invited Michael over to
tell us about Uber and this journey of
optimizing for their footprint
O2 micro
thank you thanks Alejandro uh hi folks
my name is Michael sudakovic I'm a
security engineer at tuber I also lead
the sustainability engineering team now
I mentioned security is actually an
interesting overlap a small overlap
between security and sustainability
we'll get to it in a few slides
so
before we get started just a bit of a
bird's eye view on you know
sustainability efforts at Uber right so
um we have some uh interesting green
offerings right when you uh choose your
right my right of choice is usually Uber
green matches you with a uh low emission
car electric or um or a hybrid we also
do two wheels bikes and scooters uh
uberX share uh but when it comes to
ubereats we're also working on reducing
the packaging or the unsustainable
packaging right and moving to the more
sustainable Packaging
we're helping drivers to go electric as
well investing money there and we have
transparency on our accountability and
progress so some of our goals here for
2030 uh and that's just just what six
seven years from now right we want all
of the rides in Canada Europe and the
United States be zero emission by 2040
it's uh Global right we want to be
Global uh as well as emissions from
deliveries from ubereats and and such
uh Net Zero climate emissions from all
corporate operations by 2030 and by 2040
from all of the Scopes right as Google
mentioned Scopes one two and three
so let's go let's get to the uh
engineering sustainability part right
um so our goal really is we want to
optimize for sustainability and we want
this optimization to be effortless
seamless and obvious now the way we
approach it is by looking at it in as
four steps or four verticals Right
Moving from the most manual approach to
all the way all to automated
so on the manual side right we have what
we call a wear and act so this is where
we want to invest in training in in
making sure employees Engineers
developers PMS they know what needs to
be done right they're aware of the tools
they're aware of the best practices
we'll go over some examples in a bit the
second step is what we call a system
development so this is where we come up
with automation to provide
recommendations we tell the owners the
service owners that this is what you
should probably be doing in order to
optimize
third step is essentially removing the
human from the process right we
generally want as leader Reliance on
humans in in the process if you can
automate completely then we want to do
that and again we'll see some examples
and then finally the fourth step is
sustainability by default right when we
create the resources by default we want
them all ready to be optimized for
sustainability
so with that let's move and see some
examples of the first
step the aware and act
so uh we saw earlier some of the tools
that Google provides such as the carbon
footprint dashboard
and the activist that allow us to come
up with metrics right without metrics we
can't really make informed good
decisions so we use that in order to
show the resource owners the trends
right and the metrics and see where they
are see where they want to be see where
the resources that create the most CO2
emissions are located Etc now with this
Matrix we can then go and start
optimizing at first manually right so
that's on the bottom side here so first
region selection so we've heard from
coulon uh we've heard of Alejandro and
Cynthia right that the where matters
where you deploy your resources matters
matters quite significantly right when
you look at the comparison so we want
Engineers to be aware that region
selection matters in addition to other
criteria such as maybe latency cost
right sustainability is there too
next is maximizing utilization so we
often over provision resources when we
look at is right and VM Supply provision
sometimes there's two large disks or two
large VMS with too much memory allocated
right and we don't necessarily need all
of that so we want Engineers to take a
look and see can we maximize utilization
or can we scaled down these videos
deduplication what is deduplication
sometimes we store unnecessarily copies
of data or of compute do we really need
all these versions right more data more
storage of course needs more electricity
more energy
improving code efficiency what does that
have to do here right so you know in
computer science we learn about
complexity right time complexity space
complexity so it's interesting that the
less time it takes for a program code to
run right the less compute is used the
less space it takes again the less
energy is used so we want to optimize
complexity Cod efficiency also because
it improves sustainability so maybe you
know take another look at those code
reviews right and encourage Engineers to
do what they do best
all right shared Faith this is a term
that comes often in the security field
we shared Faith with the cloud provider
when it comes to security and there's
split
um uh differences of what cloud provider
is responsible for versus the developers
now it also comes in place when we talk
about sustainability musicians because
we can use the managed offerings from
the cloud and let the cloud optimize for
us so we're going to talk about service
software as a service right we'll talk
about serverless right we try to use
these as much as possible to let the
cloud providers optimize for us
setting upper limits on scaling and
budget right and alerts as well so we
want to make sure that service owners
are aware when their services scale up
unnecessarily potentially unnecessarily
right and get an alert that might happen
because of a
uh maybe a DDOS attack might be because
we didn't
create all the resources that we need so
it might be beneficial for us to take a
look and see if there's a way to
optimize there for us to not scale up or
scale outwards unnecessarily so these
are just some of the practices that we
want Engineers to be aware of
now the Second Step some example one
example that I'll bring here this is the
assisted development right this is where
automation is in place to help
developers one example is looking at
projects and we want to look at project
life cycles we see on the left side here
there's four different states where we
sometimes or often see our projects in
the green we see project is used and
owned used you know self-explanatory oh
and there's an active owner assigned to
that project this is where we want to be
we want to have an active owner and we
want the project to be actively used
in the red right the bottom right unused
and orphan so no owner maybe they move
to a different team if they left the
company and not used in this case we
might want to eliminate this project
right carefully right first we might
want to stop remove the permissions and
then start start blocking some
functionalities and then delete this
project uh at all
now on the left bottom side used an
orphaned right so in this case we just
want to assign a new owner to this
project but this is the interesting case
now on the right upper side we have an
owner and the project is not used
this happens when you know owners just
forget about projects maybe they created
it for a POC and they just let it left
it running again unnecessarily consuming
energy creating CO2 emissions costing us
money
so for that we created automation to
create a jira ticket or a service now
ticket on the right side here and assign
it to the project owner and say hey this
is how much cost your project consumes
this is how much CO2 emissions your
project is responsible of take a look
maybe you want to delete it right so how
did we build this
so we can see the architecture on the
right side here it's pretty so simple a
cloud scheduler through Pub sub calls
Cloud functions these Cloud functions
look at each project
talk to activists remember we mentioned
active assist earlier through an API
call and use activities to serve as
source of truth that tells us whether a
project is used or not used we also look
at Cost through the billing API we look
we get our data on the CO2 emissions and
we use all that to store in firestore
and to send through Pub sub to send it
to jira servicenow in the formula of
tickets to the service owners I can also
visualize it through bigquery and data
Studio
and this is where by the way the
security comes in place as well right
there's a benefit to security by
reducing the attack surface if you
remove unnecessary services and
resources you reduce the opportunities
for end for a potential attacker to
exploit them
all right now third step the automation
right this is where we want to remove
the human from the process so one
example here is looking at the compute
again we can take a look at active
assist for recommendations will we see
sometimes that compute resources are
provisioned unnecessarily and they're
just running doing nothing right or
maybe they have disks attached to them
that are never used so in that case we
can automatically
stop these VMS without necessarily need
to delete them we can just stop it and
send a ticket or a slack message to the
resource owner saying hey we stop it for
you take a look maybe you want to delete
it
so we need to tread carefully here
because in some cases rarely in some
cases
resource owners do still need these
resources so they can decide okay fine
just I'll just resume right I'll just
resume this View
and let's get to the final uh Target
right sustainability by default so
during provisioning we already talked
about region the importance of regions
so we use ISC such as terraform to
create resources create gcp projects for
us when the uh when the service owners
need them now
we mentioned that different regions have
different sustainability metrics so what
we want to do is by default we
pre-select on the left side here see we
pre-select the four regions that are the
most sustainable in different
geographies
the other ones are not selected people
can still select them they just need to
provide the justification right why do
we need a different region but by
default we want to encourage using the
most sustainable regions to deploy
resources
And We Gather this data from the right
side through the region picker as we saw
earlier right We Gather this
sustainability data and update our form
uh automatically
so uh with that I'll pass it on to colon
for summary
much for joining the session today we
hope that you learned today new
resources and tools they can take away
to change how you work in your
organizations
foreign